اجرى مدير الاستخبارات التركيه محادثات مع
رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه عبد الحميد
بيبه في العاصمه الليبيه زياره تاتي عقبه
اخرى مما تلقم بها مدير وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه وليامبرز وتطرقت
المحادثات التي تخللت زيارتين الى المسائل
الرميه لانهاء الازمه تمهيدا لاجراء
الانتخابات في ليبيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذكاء خبر حلقتنا لنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما حيثيات اللقاءات
والاتصالات والمشورات الداخليه بين
الاطراف الليبيه وفي اي اتجاه تسير
ذلك ما طبيعه الحركه الاقليمي والدولي
بشان ليبيا وهل من اراده دوليه حقيقيه
لانهاء الانقسام وحل الازمه السياسيه في
ضوء مؤشرات بينها زياره مدير المخابرات
التركيه الى طرابلس
وكيف يتاثر هذا الحرك بالسياقات الدوليه
لا سيما حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا والدعوه
الامميه لاخراج قوه القوات الاجنبيه
والمرتزقه من ليبيا وكيف تنعكس جميع هذه
المعطيات على فرص التوسل الى حل سياسيا
يشمل جميع اطراف الازمه ويحقق الاستقرار
ليبيا
[موسيقى]
ليبيا في قلب حراك دوليا وامنيا من اجل
انهاء الازمه الجاريه في البلاد والتمهيد
للانتخابات تطوي صفحه الحرب بين اطرافها
البدايه كانت مع زياره لمدير وكاله
الاستخبارات الامريكيه وليامز وهي الزياره
التي اعقبتها اخرى بعد خمسه ايام فقط قام
بها مدير الاستخبارات التركيه الذي التقى
هو الاخر رئيس حكومه الوحده الوطنيه
الليبيه عبد الحميد بيبر زياره تتزامنوا
ودعوه مبعوث الامم المتحده للدعم في ليبيا
عبد الله باتيلي الى دعم لاعمال اللجنه
العسكريه
5+54 الى حل ملفات خلافيه بينها السبيل
الى توحيد القوه الحامله للسلاح تحت مظله
المؤسسات الشرعيه للدوله في اثناء تبحث
جلسه اسبوعيه لمجلس النواب ما توصل اليه
رئيس المجلس في لقاءاته مع رئيس المجلس
الاعلى للدوله اذا المشري بشان القاعده
الدستوريه
[موسيقى]
ولم مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من اسطنبول
نزار كريش مدير مركز بيان للدراسات
السياسيه في لبنان في ليبيا من جنيف معنى
الدكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه في جامعه جنيف اهلا بكما في ما
وراء الخبر ابدا معك استاذ نزار اذن عبد
الله بتيلي يقول
لمسنا عزمن
في اتجاه السلام والاستقرار هل من ترجمه
عمليه لهذا التصريح
هو اظننا
ما لمسه عبدالله باسيلي هو ان الجميع الان
مستعد اللي يخوض مسار السياسه بمعنى انا
الان اصبحت السياره الثانيه المسار الوحيد
سابقا كان هناك مسار عسكري ممكن ان ياخذها
الاطراف الليبيه خليفه
يعني الكتائب الموجوده في المنطقه الغربيه
اما الان فالنصار مسار وحيد هو مسار سياسي
وهذا طبعا في في كثير من النزاعات عامله
الامم المتحده بهذه الطريقه بان يكون هناك
دفع نحو السياسه ووجود القوات التركيه في
المنطقه الغربيه يعني الغت اي حلم بالتوجه
نحو طرابلس او اي يعني فرصه للسيطره بقوه
السلاح فبالتالي الان الكل منهج في ليبيا
همم الكل يبحث عن السياسه وهذه المقاربه
هي اصبحت مقاربه واضحه بمعنى ان الكل يحسب
الان في التكلفه السياسيه وليس في التكلفه
العسكريه بمعنى الان الخوف في السياسه هو
اقل ااه افضل فائده
الخوف في المجال العسكري والكل يريد نزال
مدير وكاله الاستخبارات الامريكيه ومدير
وكاله الاستخبارات التركيه يزوران طرابلس
وفي وسط كل هذا هذا ربما في قلب الموضوع
وفي جوهر تصريحات التي
يعني هذا الامر ياس في نفس السياق ربما في
المحور الاخر ياتي السياق الدولي اللي ضغط
على هذه الاطراف وجعلها يعني عاجزه تماما
لان هي دخلت في نزاع مستمر لسنوات طويله
فقدت الرؤيه فبالتالي اصبحت الان يعني
تسلم الاطراف الدوليه في البحث عن حل فهذا
يعني في نفس السياق اظن ان الجميع منهك في
الاضرار السياسيه الليبيه الجميع يبحث عن
حل همم من الخارج لجميع غير قادر على
تقديم رؤى جديده فبالتالي همم هذا ما لمسه
بتيري باتيلي وجد ان ليست مجرد هي رغبه في
السلام بل هي فرصه استراتيجيه بان الجميع
قد سلم للواقع بانه غير قادر على احداث
تغيير حقيقي في الواقع الليبي فرضيه باي
مقترح يمكن ان يصل للسلام وهذا ما ذكرته
اكثر من من تقارير حول ان مثلا خليفه حفتر
الان لا يملك القدره العسكريه ولا الماليه
للتوجه نحو العسكر فبالتالي يريد ان يطمئن
يعني يريد ان يطمئن على حتى ابناء الرجل
عمر الانسان الان فريد ان يصل الى نتيجه
معينه وهذا يعني الكل الان يفكر في
المستقبل بحيث ان اي اذا حدث اي تحول
ديمقراطي في ليبيا على الاقل تظل لهم بعض
المكاسب الا يحاسب ان يكون هناك نتائج
انتخابات عاليه في اوروبا
هل هناك فعلا ما يدل على ان هناك تقدم
بالاتجاه الصحيح ام ان تزويد تدوير لازمه
يعني في الوسط اهم عقده فيها لم تحل وهي
قضيه ان ان تجعلها متواصله بين جميع
اطرافها
يعني منذ بدايه الامم المتحده تحاول اداره
هذا النزاع لكن ليست لديه الوسائل ولا
الامكانات من اجل حل النزاع ولذلك اعتقد
ان عبد الله باتيلي مبعوث الامم المتحده
هو المستفيد الاول من هذه التحركات التي
اجرتي اليها في المقدمه وهو انه بدايه
العمل كانت متعفره ويراهن على همم وراهن
على التقدم في مجموعه خمسه زائد خمسه زائد
خمسه التي استطاعت فعلا ان تقدم الكثير
فيما يخص مثلا الحفاظ على الهدنه لكن هو
يريد يعني يريد ان يعطيها دور متقدم وربما
حتى يكون هناك دور سياسي في محاوله توحيد
المؤسسه العسكريه
سيقدم قريبا حاضر مجلس الامن وهو يحتاج في
النهايه ماده يمكن ان يقدمها الى مجلس
الامن حول الوضع في ليبيا وهو كذلك ما
يفسر هذه التحركات الاقليميه اما اعتقد
يعني ما جاء من زميلي من تركيا صحيح وان
هناك الان حاله اعياء
لكن كل الاطراف الداخليه ما زال تحتك في
البي ام مش من الحركه ودخول الولايات
المتحده ومعظم مهم ليس على المستوى الدولي
فقد حتى على المستوى المحلي لان الاقتناع
ده بطيلي ولا اقتناع كذلك حتى الدول
الغربيه ان فقط الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه اذا رمت بكل اياها باسباب جهويه
والدوليه يمكن فعلا ان تثني الاطراف
الاقليميه التي ما زالت تحرك الاعتراف
المحليه على التدخل سينما في الموضوع
الليبي لان قضايا مثلا قضايا الدستور
وقضايا قوانين انتخابيه تبقى حكم لليبيين
لكن ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
الاقل ان تساهم في همم حد التاثير السلبي
للدول الاقليميه يعتبر هذا انجاز بالنسبه
لي طيب
الحديث عن الاعياء يعني يبدو ان كليكما
يركزان على هذه النقطه الاطراف كلها اصيبت
بحاله من الاعلاء واعود اليك استاذ نزار
همم يعني لفتني ما جاء في تصريح بتيلي على
ان القوات المسلحه هناك تاكيد على هذه
النقطه ان القوات المسلحه تدعم هذا المسار
هل في هذا الدلاله خاصه
نعم هذا يعني هذا هذه معلومات
العيال التي ذكرناها او حاله ال ال الناس
يعني بمعنى اخر همم الان لا يعني هل انت
تقاتل الى اي ماده ستظل تقاتل الى اي مدى
لا يمكنك ان تؤثر في المشهد الكل يشعر
بانه يدور في حلقه مفرغه فبالتالي حتى
خليفه حفتر الان اصبح يخوض في المجال
السياسي ويبحث عن حلول ويرسل في ابنائها
الى تركيا ويرسل في ابنائها الى باقي
الاطراف ويتحاور مع الجميع بمعنى انه دخل
في في في في في في تونس السياسه وهذا هذا
هذا هذا اظن ان ما ذكره يعني غسان سلامه
من قبل وما حدث حتى في في في كثير من
الحروب الاهليه باننا لا ت همم تغلق الباب
العسكري من خلال قوه اقليميه مثل ما حدث
في ليبيريا بتدخل قوات افريقيه ثم بعد ذلك
ترغم الجميع على الدخول في حلبه السياسه
لان ليس الان مجال عسكره فهذا همم قضيه
تطور مهم في الشان الليبي لكن ما ينقص
اللي بين الان بالصح انا اوافق ان الذين
مجال حركه لكن هذا المجال الحركه الاعاقه
التقدم مثلا مجلس النواب ممكن ان يعيق
للانتخابات المجلس الاعلى للدوله عبد
الحميد بيبا ممكن ان يعيق الحركه بين
الشرق والغرب والتوحيد المؤسسات لكن لا
احد يملك رؤيه للتقدم للامان عبد الله
بديل الان يمضي في مسار اخر تماما هو يعني
ليس سرا بانه يريد ان لجنه جديده وهذه
اللجنه ستكون مثل لجنه 75 وستجتمع وتحاول
ان تضع حاله الطريق بل ذهب البعض بين
الحديث عن هذه اللجنه الجديده سيكون لها
يعني ان هي من تضع القاعده الدستوريه وما
هي تضع قانون الانتخابات اذا ماذا في هذا
الطريق اظن انه سيستخدم سيستفيد من حاله
الاعياء وعدم وجود اي رؤيه لدى الاطراف
الليبيه لوضع سلطه تاسيسيه جديده تبتعد عن
اطراف النزاع بمعنى ان يكون هناك مجموعه
من العقلاء بدل من يكون يمثلون اطراف
النزاع يمثلون الحكم بين هؤلاء المتنازعون
في ليبيا وهذه نقل جيده في وجود وضع
اقليمي ودولي ممكن نتحدث عينه
يساهم في هذا المجال طبعا زيارات نعم لو
افترضنا انه فعلا هناك حاله اعياء ليبيه
سواء على المستوى السياسي او العسكري
دكتور حسني عبيدي وفي النهايه لا يمكن ان
ننسى ان ليبيا كانت ملعبا لاجندات اقليميه
ودوليه كثيره هناك قوات مسلحه مرتزقه
موجوده داخلها من خارج ليبيا واقعيا
وفعليا هل يعني نتوقع ان نرى همم تفاعل
ايجابي مع اخراج هذه القوه او اعياء ايضا
في الاجزدات الاقليميه والدوليه
يعني تضارب الايرادات الداخليه لكل
الاطراف الليبيه شرقا شرقا وغربا وجنوب
اعتقد هو الذي جعل ليبيا من احد اسباب
لجعلت ليبيا رهينه المصالح الاجنبيه التي
في النهايه وجدت وجدت ااا الاطراف المحليه
التي يمكن ان تقوم بهذا الدور لكن اعتقد
ان حتى الاطراف الاجنبيه الان وصلت الى
طريق مسدود حيث ان في النهايه المكاسب
يعني اصبحت ضئيله ثم ان هناك دوله اخرى
دخلت وانا اعتقد الموضوع يرجع الى ترامب
يعني سفير الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
ذلك في ليبيا كان من الذي اعطى دفعه قويه
وقال بانه لا يمكن ان نترك ليبيا يعني في
يعني في هذا في منتصف همم الطريق
الوجود القوات الاجنبيه يمكن ان ان يحل
باعتبار ان انه المتحده هي تعتقد بانه فتح
جبهات عند الجبهات في نفس في ان واحد صعب
جدا نبدا قبل كل شيء بقضيه سياسيه وانا
اتفق ك مع الراي القائل بان استنساخ
استنساخ ما يسمى بمنتدى جناب الذي افضى
الى حكومه البيبه يمكن كذلك ان يتم عن
طريق البكتيلي بطريقه اخرى بطريقه ذكيه
وهو وهو اخراج جسم سياسي جديد هذا الجسم
هو الذي سيبد في القضايا المتعلقه مثلا
بقضايا قضايا القوات الاجنبيه مع التفريق
والولايات المتحده وحتى الامم المتحده
يعني الفرق ما بين القوات مثلا التركيه
حتى نتحدث عن الموضوع وقوه فاجنر واعتقد
ان واحد اسباب وجود او زياره ولي امبارز
وحتى الاهتمام الامريكي المتزايد حتى في
الكونجرس هي قضيه الوجود الروسي والكذلك
وتدعيات لهذا الوجود على افريقيا التي
تعتبر
مهمه وكذلك على حرب الاخرى التي استثمر
فيها الولايات المتحده
نزار قبل الحديث عن اخراج جسم سياسي كما
اشار الدكتور حسني همم الكل يبدو منشغل
باخراج القوات الاجنبيه والمرتزقه من
ليبيا هل تراه شرقا ساب شرقا سابقا ام
لاحقا لمسار التسويه
سيكون لاحق وليس سابق القوه الغربيه الان
اظنيه تنظر لشمال افريقيا ولا تنظر لليبيا
وحدها بمعنى ان الان انت امام منطقه شرق
الاوسط امام همم منطقه الشرق الاوسط تعاني
من مشاكل كبيره في سوريا في العراق عن
امامك انت بحر الاسود وبحر قزوين ومشاكل
اللي في اوكرانيا كل هذا المسار يبدو
مغلقا وروسيا تهدد اوروبا في مجال الطاقه
الان يعني هناك ورقه لرئيس الوزراء
الايطالي يتحدث عن شمال افريقيا جديد
ويقول ان كل المشاكل العالم الان متمثله
في شمال افريقيا في في افريقيا في طاقه في
افريقيا فيه ايراني وفي افريقيا فيه ماء
في افريقيا في مواني في 500 مليون مستهلك
في شرق المتوسط في 30 لترليون متر مكعب من
الغاز من الممكن ان يكفي اوروبا لمده 30
سنه كل هذه المسارات جعلت الرؤيه
استراتيجيه لشمال افريقيا وفي القلب منها
ليبيا لكن كيف يمكن التعامل مع ليبي اظن
ما نلاحظه وما نراقبه انه في كام راقبين
لش الحاله الليبيه التسارع الوتيره التدخل
الغربي تسارع وتيره التدخل في الغرب في
ليبيا والاهم من ذلك وتسارع الفعل الغربي
في ليبيا بمعنى الزيارات هذه المتتاليه
همم لزياره الرئيس المخابرات الامريكي
التركي قبلها كان هناك وجود فرقاطه
بريطانيه خلال ايام كانت في بريطانيا
نتيجه لاحداث بعض الاحداث في ليبيا لا
تنسى الى المنطقه الشمالي الافريقيه الان
هي يعني مستقبل العالم لماذا انت امام
افريقيا فيها كثير من المواد النادره اللي
موجوده في كل الصناعات همم اوروبا ليس لها
مجال الا افريقيا الان الرؤيه
الاستراتيجيه التي تواجه اوروبا الان
كيفيه ايجاد مجال حيوي في بحر الابيض
المتوسط وهناك دراسات كثيره في هذا المجال
فالامر لا يتعلق فقط
يعني عقده في منشار رؤيه استراتيجيه فمن
يعطل كل هذا هو اللي بيقول انفسهم يعني
اللي كانهم يلعبوا في شطرنج مع لعيب كبير
وهم لا يفهمون
موجوده عا- عقيمه بمعنى نعم بما نكرت الى
المستقبل همم نتوقف فقط الى اين تسير
ليبيا مستقبلا رئيس حكومه الوحده الليبيه
عبد الحميد دبيبه يقول ان بلاده لن تحكمها
اي سلطه عسكريه مره اخرى مذكرا ان من ضحوا
بارواحهم انما كانوا يطلبون امورا من بين
اهمها انتخابات وطنيه
وهذا اكبر تحدي بالنسبه لنا اليوم وهو ان
يكونوا هم نور طريقنا
وبوصله اتجاهنا نحو المحافظه على وحده
ليبيا وعزه اهلها وان تكون نهايه هذه
المراحل الانتقاليه منذ انتصار ثوره 17
فبراير هي انتخابات وطنيه تنتهي وتنهي عبد
كل الاجسام التي تحاول تضيع التضحيات
شهداء
دكتور حسني عبيدي انتخابات دوليه هي هذا
المخرج كما يراه الدبيبه ولكن فعليا اي
خطوه كهذا تحتاج دعم من الخارج هل ترى في
ذلك عائقا ام فرصه حقيقيه لحل الازمه
اكتشفت بان مخرجات برلين واحد وبرلين
اثنين رغم انها كانت طموحه وكانت بحضور
تقريبا كل الفاعلين الدوليين والاقليين
ولا لم تؤدي في النهايه لانفراجه كبيره
الان اعتقد انه الظرفيه الدوليه ثم كذلك
كما قلت الطريقه المسدوده الان امام
الاطراف المحليه في ليبيا ربما يكون هو
فرصه
لمحاوله
تحيين المقاربه الخاصه بليبيا انت اشترتها
الى قضيه المؤسسه العسكريه والحكم انا
اعتقد القبائل الخلفيه التي سببت حتى في
تاجيل في الانتخابات القناه المتعلقه
بالقانون
الوثيقه الدستوريه الى ذلك هي قضيه شاقه
ما يمكن للدول الغربه الغربيه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي ان ان ان تضغط على
كل الاطراف من اجل الوصول الى لنقل الى حل
توافقي للجميع لكن من الصعب قول انه لن
يصير عسكريا الى السلطه انا اعتقد او قضيه
شروط الترشح للانتخابات الى غردايه هذه
القبائل التي ستحكم وفي النهايه في هذا
الخطاب هي اشاره اكيد الى الى الى الجهه
الشرقيه
الذي يبقى حاضرا في الغرفه كما يقول المثل
الامريكي وهنا السؤال استاذ نزار كريكش
يعني هل هذا هو ما يختزم الازرق السؤال
هذا هل سيسمح لي حفتر ان يترشح للانتخابات
رغم ماضي هل فعلا هذا هو ما سيدور حوله كل
الموضوع وسيكون ج- يعني الحل جوهر الخلاف
الان هذا هذه النقطه
نعم هو الان هو هو اظن انه هو محاوله
بمعنى ايجاد
بيئه تسمح باستقبال حفتر سياسيه وهذا يعني
كانه ترويض للعمليه السياسيه لاستقبال
حفتر وهذا طبعا
سيعتمد على المسار الذي ياخذه عبد الله
باسيلي ما حدث في ليبيا الان ان الاطراف
السياسيه مدت جذور لبعضها البعض يعني مجلس
النواب والمجلس الاعلى للدوله خالد المصري
عقيله صالح فتحي باشا ومعهم حتى خليفه
حفتر في المقابل في المنطقه الغربيه هناك
كتله اقتصاديه رجال اعمال همم مؤسسات
الدوله بعض الشبكات المستفيده من المصالح
من النظام السابق كلها اتحدت مع بعض اذا
عندنا
رهط سياسي اقتصادي وكل منهما يحاول ان
يسيطر على المشهد ويرصل المشهد المستقبل
بما يخدم مصالحه اذا حفتر الان يريد ان
يتوضا هو احيانا يتم موضوع صالح يريد ان
يكسب بعض القوانين انتخابات وحينما يايايا
اسم هؤلاء ينتقد الى عبد الحميد بيبه
ويحاول ان يوفر الاموال التي تضمن له
سلطته في المنطقه الشرقيه لذلك هو الان في
منطقه رخوه تماما من يمد له حبل النجاه اي
مسار سياسي الان سيرسم مستقبل خليفه حفتر
اذا اتبع عبد الله بتيجي المسار الذي اتخذ
غسان سلامه بايجاد لجنه 75 هي مجرد ديكور
لوضع همم يعني خارطه جديده سيدخل حفتر في
المجال اما اذا كانت هذه اللجنه هي لجنه
همم محكمه وليست تعبر عن اطراف النزاع
بمعنى ان قادره على ايجاد قانون يضمن
استقرار ليبيا ولا يحقق مصالح الاطراف
الدول الاقليميه الدول المجتمع الدولي
بشكل عام ان يفعله في هذا السياق
الذي يعمل الكثير ان اعتقد ان الضغط
والتاثير مباشره ااه على الدول الفاعله
هناك دور مصري هناك دور كذلك خليجي هناك
دور تركي يعني لا يمكن ان نقد ان نطالب
الاطراف الليبيه الداخليه ان تتفق وتجد
حال توافقي ولا نطلب كذلك من الدول الاخرى
المحيطه ان تتوافق على مساعده الليبيين من
اجل الوصول الى مقاربه جديده للازمه
الليبي اشكرك يا دكتور حسني عبيدي استاذ
العلاقه الدوليه في جامعه جنيف واشكرك
نزار كريش مدير مركز بيان للدراسات
السياسيه في ليبيا كنت معنا من اسطنبول
وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا الكرام على متابعه هذه
الحلقه من ما وراء الخبر
[موسيقى]